on pèle des fruits et légumes depuis
toujours et tout a été inventé pour nous
faciliter la tâche
mais les chefs sont unanimes il n'y a
rien de mieux que l'économe l'épicerie
en atteste et 16 dont les prix varient
de 4 à 25 dollars qu'est ce qu'on
demande à un est calme ce serait quoi
les principales qualités art
naturellement ça prend une bonne poignée
une bonne prise quelque chose qui
glissent pas quand c'est mouillé ça soit
confortable surtout quand on reçoit on
ne de sacs de pommes de terre la pluie
ça prend une excellente lam lam qui
coupent bien qui vaut couper longtemps
ça prend aussi un système pour bien
injecter l'épaule eurent c'est important
que les pleurs reste pas prise dans
l'âme
bien sûr on pense à la pomme de terre la
carotte mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut
éplucher d'autres avec ce petit objet
n'est pas qu'elle helmand qui ont une
peau personnellement j'ai toujours fait
mes courjault couteau mais j'essayais
avec l'économe c'est une très belle
épreuve parce que la peau quand même
très très haut luxe on veut rester une
range aussi j'essayais le kiwi aussi
parce que c'est une bois c'est une
particulière on peut faire des copeaux
de chocolat des copeaux de parmesan
donc c'est vraiment un outil qui peut
être très versatile eux c'est pour ça
qu'un des critères de sélection c'était
vraiment la versatilité aussi nous avons
mené nos tests sur neuf modèles à lame
droite et 7 à la perpendiculaire
le modèle avec un homme perpendiculaire
tout ce qui est produit qui est long on
fonctionne très bien pour les petits à
l'image d'un petit peu plus difficile ça
demande une dextérité peut-être mais moi
je connais pas sur la fête les l'idc
s'est fait comme ça vers toi l'abri le
modèle droit selon moi se manipule
beaucoup mieux dans toutes les
directions et de dextérité aussi faut-il
faire usage en manipulant les trois
modèles
lame dentelée ici s'il te plaît plus
agressif ça ça vaut toujours coupées
mais ça a compulsé les bouts de doigts
se coupent les ponts demain et ça
déchire les linges à vaisselle ou si
deux modèles semblent est dangereux
le kitchen aid et le cuisine art à deux
lames l'orne la dame pour éplucher et on
a mis 6 pour faire dès juillet mais le
danger c'est vrai que mon post glissé
que j'avais coupé g mais coupé le pouce
sur les lames si brillante aussi la
texture des peluches et avec un we know
it oad maintenant membre personnes nous
avons été rapidement mesure d'établir
quels sont les modèles qui ne se
retrouveront pas au sommet de notre
palmarès
ils ont développé un dézingue fait que
la pelure est vraiment éjecté vers la
main mais son gros défaut c'est fait que
l'homme coupe dans un sens seulement
donc c'est le seul qui n'ait pas
ambidextre
à surveiller aussi l'épaisseur des
épluchures
s'il est trop mince il va peut-être
falloir passer plusieurs fois pour bien
éplucher notre élément c'est trop
épaisse mais naturellement on va perdre
de la nourriture le moins cher du lot
l'ancêtre des économes était le plus
gourmand et le moins confortable
celui là ici le mans je suis plus ou
moins confortable mais c'est surtout que
la lame vraiment fait très très très
épais j'ai l'idée c'est d'être économe 1
2 po gaspiller nos animaux les modèles
perpendiculaire swiss m'a tout comme le
victorinox se sont avérés un confortable
aussi la lame fixe a juste le zwin le
seul
alan fixe demande beaucoup de dextérité
et offre un espace de coupe très étroit
à preuve ce malheureux kiwi cellule
ayons eu l'intelligence de maintenir go
sur chaque côté donc dépendamment si je
suis gaucher ou si je suis droitier mais
là comme dans le manche positionne le
poignet l'année dont deux faces drôle de
façon
tous les modèles sont munis d'ergo pour
retirer les yeux de pommes de terre des
ergots pathos fonctionnel et puis
ici qu'il n'est pas confortable et que
les ergots ici sont absolument nulle
cinq modèles mérite une mention
honorable dont le ricardo qui a plu sur
presque toute la ligne seul bémol il
tranche peut-être trop mais ce qui
nécessite plus de passage sur l'aliment
est vraiment le plus économe de toulouse
et colonnes le modèle dentelée de
victorinox fonctionne quand même assez
bien le tefal confortable en main mais
sa lame un peu trop souple temps à se
déformer pour les produits un peu plus
dur
la lame se défend sa mort trop ça bloque
où on va vous en faire que la pelouse
vraiment
enfin les modèles perpendiculaire au kso
et conneries qu'on munis de petits
manche et deux courtes aux lames sont
efficaces mais un peu moins versatiles
après une poche de patates
nous avons couronner nos deux gagnants
le oxo good grips droit et le tefal
perpendiculaire c'est définitivement les
deux qui offre le plus de versatilité
plus de performances une épaisseur de
peuls qui est acceptable qui sont hyper
confortable aussi
[Musique]